Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and since we’ve
only got a couple more episodes left in Walking
Dead this season I thought it was time to
do some more predictions.
So here’s 10 things I think will or in some
cases will not happen.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I’m also doing a weekly giveaway in all
my Walking Dead review videos just to say
thanks for be so awesome.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment.
The next round starts Sunday.
So let’s predict some awful things.
Careful for spoilers if you’re not caught
up on Season 4 yet.
But here we go.
Number 10 - Lizzie and Mika are the new Billy
and Ben from the comics.
So based on what’s happening on the show
right now, around this time in the comics
two little twin boys appeared named Billy
and Ben.
Ben started torturing and killing animals
just like Lizzie has been doing.
Ultimately Ben in the comics kills his brother
Billy.
He’s completely nuts, and based on the way
Lizzie has been behaving since the season
came back, especially with baby Judith.
It seems like she and Mika are taking the
place of the brothers in the comics.
In the teaser for episode 14 you can see the
Mika on the ground with Walkers coming after
her and Carol crying.
It implies that Mika will get bitten.
Based on Billy and Ben’s story line that
would suggest that Lizzie will then kill Mika
to prevent her from turning.
So yes she’s murdering her sister, but she
was infected so it wouldn’t be quite as
bad as it was in the comics.
The show does that a lot, where they change
things from the comics so that they’re still
really bad, but not quite as graphic.
So essentially Lizzie will end up killing
Mika or it’s also possible that she’ll
try to kill her and Tyreese and Carol will
stop her.
Ben’s plot in the comics involves Carl so
they’ll have to change it a little no matter
what.
Number 9 - Maggie and Glenn are reunited
A lot of you were asking if Glenn was geographically
behind Maggie in the last episode.
Based on the amount of time the show dedicated
to showing her insane finger painting scene
I think he is.
At the very least, they’ll meet up at Terminus
in the finale.
It’s hard to guess where everyone is chronologically
just because the episodes jump around in time.
For instance, remember the person in Joe’s
gang that Daryl ran into.
He’s the same guy that ended up on the floor
in front of Rick.
So what’s been happening as we jump from
group to group is that they’re telling the
story of everyone during the same period of
time.
Most of them have been on foot the whole time
too, so they haven’t gone too far from the
prison.
Forgetting for a sec about what happens in
the comics to their characters, I think they
will at least get a moment of reunion.
Just the relief of having found each other.
Inevitably something awful will probably happen
to them after that though.
Number 8 - All of the groups will meet at
Terminus.
I talked a little about this in my last Q&A
video but there have been so many visual references
to the Terminus for all of the groups.
It would be crazy if they didn’t all end
up there.
Glenn is the furthest away, just because they
spent a couple hours on the road to Washington
DC, but we saw him staring at a Terminus map
last week.
There’s this really cool old Anton Chekov
quote saying that a gun must never be placed
on stage if it’s never going to go off.
It’s about the narrative of a story, meaning
don’t make promises you don’t intend to
keep.
And showing Glenn with the Terminus map is
kind of like a promise that he’s going there.
The only real question is when he’ll finally
meet Maggie, either in the finale or right
before the finale.
We don’t have any info on the plot of episode
15 yet.
Number 7 - Daryl’s Group won’t be the
Hunters or The Saviors
Right now they’re being referred to as the
Marauders, who appeared a long time ago in
the comics.
But because Joe’s group is a lot bigger
than the Mauraders they’re a lot closer
to The Hunters.
The problem with calling them the Hunters
is 1, we haven’t seen them eat anyone yet.
And Two, they’re very disorganized and chaotic.
Please refer back to jerkoff’s strangling
each other while Rick hid under the bed.
The other option is the Saviors, but the reason
I don’t think they’re the Saviors is because
that group is heavily tied to Negan and the
Sanctuary.
Which, based on everything Robert Kirkman
has said, is a Season 5 thing.
If they’re not Hunters, Mauraders or Saviors,
they’re just a new group the show created.
I do think that they’re attached to the
Terminus though.
They’re not just a random group of bandits.
Number 6 - Terminus will be a version of The
Hilltop Colony
The Hilltop colony is a place Rick and the
survivors go before the Alexandria Safe Zone
and before The Sanctuary.
Additionally, it has one specific character
that I’ll talk about in a sec.
Hilltop Colony as a story point sets up a
lot of the things we know are coming, like
Negan and Alexandria.
And it provides a place for a villain that’s
not a really huge character like the Governor
or Negan.
Robert Kirkman said the whole reason in not
doing Negan right away was to give the story
time to breathe between those two characters
who are currently the two most epic villains
in the comic books.
Number 5 - There won’t be any Negan, but
the new character Gareth will be a version
of Jesus
Jesus is the antagonist at Hilltop Colony
that I just mentioned.
His real name is Paul Monroe and early on
he’s not really as much of a villain as
a character no one trusts.
He’s a really good fighter, so if Gareth
is the Jesus character we will probably get
to see him fight Abraham and Michonne like
in the comic book.
Jesus lets all the other survivors know about
the existence of Negan and The Saviors.
Mostly that they’re awful.
But the Hilltop and Jesus are the precursor
to Alexandra.
And the name of Episode 16, the finale is
“A”.
So it makes sense that this is how the story
will progress.
Number 4 - Gareth took Beth to Terminus
Because there was a cross on the back of the
car and the whole house looked like a trap,
everyone thought The Hunters or The Saviors
might be involved.
But I think the cross could also be a visual
reference to the Jesus character.
Who is a little shady, but well meaning.
That would mean that Gareth did take Beth,
but only to help her.
Which still doesn’t answer the question
as to the House trap or why someone would
have led the Walkers to the house.
It’s possible that the Gareth character
is a combination of Jesus from the Hilltop
Colony and the Gabriel character.
Gabriel’s story did involve the Hunters
and Dale getting captured, it happens in the
comics before Hilltop colony too.
So the show could just be mashing a lot of
things together.
Number 3 - Everyone will learn about Negan
Negan is the leader of the Saviors, a really
sinister group that extorts money and does
terrible things to people in exchange for
protection from the Walkers.
By all accounts he won’t be on the show
in a big way at least until Season 5.
Everyone learns about him while they’re
at Hilltop Colony.
Where Negan gets a lot of his supplies.
His story crosses over to the Alexandra Safe
Zone, so if the finale is going to tease Alexandria,
it will also have to tease Negan.
All of this also involves a lot of Carl, which
means Chandler Riggs will potentially have
a much more interesting story next season.
Which I think is great.
I think of Negan as being the most evil version
of Rick, which means there’s a real potential
for mirroring Carl’s relationship with Rick.
Number 2 - Everyone will learn about the Alexandria
Safe Zone.
Alexandria Safe Zone is like the next Prison
location.
A big walled area where everyone is safe from
Walkers.
The name of the finale is “A” and that
seems like the biggest teaser you could possibly
do for Alexandria.
A lot of that story is tied up with Negan
and the Saviors, so I don’t think anyone
will get there until season 5.
A lot of people thought the radio message
Daryl heard was from there, but really I think
that was just from Terminus.
Number 1 - There will be two more major deaths,
not just one.
Remember how Lizzie is basically turning into
or is already the Ben character.
Meaning she’ll either try to kill Mika or
will get killed herself.
Either way I think it means one of the girls
is going to die.
My other prediction is a little complicated.
There was a rumor that a character that’s
still alive in the comics is going to die
on the show.
Which really narrows it down.
Most of the people that are dead in the comics
are already dead on the show.
And there are a few characters on the show
that aren’t in the comics, so we have to
exclude them.
Meaning Daryl and Beth probably won’t die.
My earlier prediction last year was that it
would be Maggie.
Depending on whether or not the show is going
to bring out The Hunters I may have to revise
this, but for now I’m sticking with her.
So let me know, who do you think is going
to die.
And do you think Lizzie will try to kill Mika
or baby Judith.
The teaser for the next episode really does
make it seem like someone is going to die
from the look on Carol’s face.
Like I said, new giveaway round begins on
Sunday in my review video, be sure to subscribe
to get it.
Only three more episodes to go.
Right now click here for my last walking dead
video and click here for the rest of my predictions
from last year.
Some of them have already come true.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight.
High Fives!